en vídeos anteriores presentamos la idea
de la función de producción que incluye
varios insumos
llamemos a este insumo 1 insumo 2 insumo
3 con base en la cantidad de los
diversos insumos que tengas la función
de producción va a proporcionar de tu
producción total a diferentes cantidades
de insumos en este vídeo vamos a limitar
todos los insumos a excepción de uno
para mostrar la variación de nuestra
producción en función de un solo insumo
y mientras lo hacemos podremos entender
estas ideas de producto total producto
marginal y producto medio de modo que
para ver un ejemplo tangible digamos que
estamos administrando una fábrica de
helados y queremos saber cuánto varía
nuestra producción de helados por día en
función de la cantidad de personas que
trabajan en la fábrica
déjenme escribir esto producción de
helados por día voy a dibujar una tabla
de este lado entonces de nuestra primera
columna voy a poner el trabajo que sería
la entrada para ver cómo este insumo
determina la producción
por eso voy a poner trabajo que podría
medirse como trabajadores por día
trabajadores y vamos a ver cómo varía
nuestra producción si tenemos cero
trabajadores un trabajador por día dos
trabajadores por día o tres trabajadores
por día
ahora nuestra siguiente columna será
nuestra producción y diremos que es
nuestro producto total en función del
número de trabajadores pt producto total
y digamos que sabemos que si no hay
personas trabajando en nuestra fábrica
de helados bueno vamos a producir 0
galones de helado y supongamos que
nuestra producción está en galones por
día
si tenemos un trabajador en nuestra
fábrica bueno entonces podremos producir
10 galones por día si tenemos dos
trabajadores en nuestra fábrica
produciremos 18 galones por día si
tenemos 3 trabajadores en nuestra
fábrica digamos que podemos producir 24
galones por día lo suficientemente justo
ahora voy a presentar una idea y
seguramente has visto esta palabra
marginal en otros momentos del curso de
economía
voy a introducir el producto marginal de
los trabajadores
y la manera de pensar en el marginal es
cuánto es el incremento de una cosa
cuando adiciones de la otra cosa
de modo que nuestro producto marginal de
trabajo dice que por cada unidad
adicional de trabajo es decir por cada
persona más que trabaja aquí por día
cuántos galones más de helado estoy
produciendo entonces mi producto
marginal del trabajo cuando voy de cero
trabajadores a un trabajador es de 10
galones más de ese primer trabajador
ahora qué pasa cuando paso de un
trabajador a dos trabajadores
pues bien voy de 10 a 18 galones así que
esa segunda persona me da un incremento
de 8 galones por día y luego al pasar de
dos personas que trabajan allí a tres
personas bueno mi producto total aumenta
en seis mi producto marginal de trabajo
para ese tercer trabajador será igual a
seis
ahora hay algo interesante que vemos
aquí de inmediato esto en realidad es
bastante típico y es que el producto
marginal del trabajo muchas veces
disminuirá a medida que se agreguen más
trabajadores y podrías preguntarte por
qué pasa eso
bueno simplemente no van a ser tan
productivos esa segunda persona podría
estar esperando a que la primera persona
termine de usar la mezcladora y esa
tercera persona estará esperando a la
primera persona y a la segunda persona
tal vez estén usando el baño o algo así
y la tercera persona tiene que irse
y puedes imaginar que agregas a 4 a 5 o
a 6 y en algún momento ni siquiera serás
capaz de incluir a más personas en la
fábrica por lo que tendrás esta
situación que se conoce como rendimiento
marginal decreciente y lo puedes ver
justo aquí a medida que agregas más y
más trabajadores el rendimiento marginal
es cada vez más pequeño por lo que
tenemos un rendimiento marginal
decreciente
ahora el último concepto que les
presentaré en este vídeo es el del
producto medio y este es el producto
medio en función del trabajo por lo
tanto pm para el producto medio y es
igual a nuestro producto total dividido
entre nuestro trabajo así que aquí
cuando tenemos un trabajador nuestro
producto total es de 10 galones y lo
dividiremos entre un trabajador entonces
nuestro producto promedio por trabajador
será de 10 galones ahora cuando tenemos
dos personas trabajando por día y
estamos produciendo 18 galones por día
nuestro producto promedio en función del
trabajo será igual a 18 dividido entre 2
lo que en promedio será 9 galones por
trabajador por día
y luego esta última situación será igual
a 24 dividido entre 3 lo que equivale a
un promedio de 8 galones por trabajador
por día
también podemos ver esto gráficamente
puedo dibujar esto en una curva
déjenme hacerlo
en nuestro eje horizontal tengo las
unidades del trabajo que son
trabajadores por día 1 2 3
aquí tenemos trabajo
en nuestro eje vertical tenemos producto
total digamos que son 10 20 y 30 justo
aquí bueno primero veamos este de aquí
cuando tenemos a una persona trabajando
en la fábrica producimos 10 galones por
día cuando tenemos dos personas
trabajando en nuestra fábrica producimos
18 galones por día sería algo así
y fíjense la pendiente ha bajado un poco
tenemos una cierta pendiente aquí pero
acá está un poco menos empinada y la
inclinación de esa línea o de esa curva
nos dice algo sobre el producto marginal
es un poco menos empinada por lo que
nuestro producto marginal del trabajo se
ha reducido un poco estamos teniendo
rendimientos marginales decrecientes y
por último pero no menos importante
cuando tenemos a tres personas
trabajando podemos producir 24 por lo
que 3 y 24 pueden estar justo aquí y una
vez más podemos ver que nuestros
rendimientos decrecientes se vuelven
incluso un poco más planos pasamos de 0
a 1 agregamos 10 y lo podemos ver en el
producto marginal del trabajo y cuando
agregamos a una persona más tenemos 8
más y luego agregamos otra persona y
tenemos 6 más en general si ves el
producto total en función del trabajo o
la producción total como una función del
trabajo y la curva es cada vez menos
empinada
esto te dice que tu producto marginal es
cada vez más bajo y estás obteniendo
rendimientos marginales decrecientes
hasta el próximo vídeo